patient
as you all just saw this afternoon the
president was out in the Rose Garden
alongside with family caregivers people
with disabilities long-term care workers
people
long-term care workers early Educators
veterans and aging Advocates signed an
executive order to expand access to
Affordable high quality care and provide
support for care workers and family
caregivers the this executive order
which includes more than 50 directives
for agencies across the government is
the most comprehensive set of executive
actions by by any president has ever
taken to make care more affordable and
accessible for hard-working families and
further support care workers and family
caregivers the reality is that too many
families are struggling to access the
affordable high quality care they need
and too many care workers lack the
support they need to do their critical
work and are leaving the workforce
the results have hurt our economy and
American workers particularly women
President Biden wants to change our
trajectory and transform care in this
country and that is reflected in his
fiscal year 2024 budget President Biden
has also also wants to ensure taxpayers
get the best value for Investments we've
already made by making by helping to
make American families access care all
while supporting care workers and family
caregivers and growing our economy as
well and that is exactly what this
executive order will do
now this next uh topper here that I have
it's just one it feels like every week
at least once a week I come to the
podium and I talk about this gun
violence epidemic that we're seeing
across the country and how our
communities and families Across America
yet again have been devastated by tragic
acts of gun violence and it is not just
devastating for me I'm sure it's
devastating for all of you and your
families it's devastating for this
President it's devastating for our
Administration and to have to continue
to do that over and over again and and
uh so let me just lay out sadly what we
have seen these last couple of days four
young people killed at a sweet 16 party
in Dadeville Alabama
two killed and four others injured on
Saturday night in a crowded public park
in Louisville a bright young loving 16
year old kid Ralph yarl shot in the head
in Missouri after ringing the wrong
doorbell
and we just learned
a few hours ago about 12 hours ago about
a young woman 20 or 20 year old
woman in Upstate New York who was killed
for turning down the wrong driveway
and these are just some of the tragedies
that actually have made the headlines
as you saw from the president he and the
first lady are grieving for those killed
and the many others injured and fighting
fighting for their lives in the wake of
this gun violence that we're seeing
across the country
the president had the chance to speak on
the phone with Ralph last night in
addition to talking about Ralph's
success in high school in in high school
his hopes for the future and wishing him
a speedy recovery the president
committed to Ralph and his mom
as he has committed to so many other
survivors that he will continue to fight
for gun safety reforms
that's because action on gun safety is
what we owe it is what we owe to those
who have had their lives stolen from
them
and it is what the American people want
to see majority of the American people
want to see us take action
despite that last week we saw many
national Republican elected officials
stand alongside NRA
in a race to the bottom on dangerous
dangerous laws that further erode gun
safety
though the proposals they're pushing
take us in the wrong direction at a time
when we're seeing gun violence surging
particularly gun deaths of our children
now this stat as you've heard me say
many times the president put it in his
statement recently
guns is the leading cause of death in
our children
so as the president has said he wants to
work across the aisle in good faith on
federal legislation that will save lives
it is within congress's power to require
safe storage of firearms require
background checks for all guns gun sales
eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liability and ban assault weapons
and also high capacity magazines and he
continues to believe this should happen
without delay this is something that
they can do today if they chose
okay on to uh the next topic as you saw
on Friday the Supreme Court temporarily
paused the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals decision that just like the
Texas District Court's decision attempts
to disregard
FDA scientific judgment regarding mifa
Preston
this Administration continues to stand
by fda's evidence-based approval of mifa
Preston and the agency's independent
expert authority to review approve and
regulate a wide range of prescription
drugs in recent weeks we've seen
hundreds of pharmaceutical companies and
Executives attorney generals from across
the country and members of Congress all
speak out against the dangerous
precedent this court decision could set
if it does stand
we've seen even conservative legal
Scholars commentators and Ed boards like
Wall Street Journal all point out the
flaws in the Court's reasoning
I have said this many times that the
District Court's decision or the fifth
circuit's decision is upheld it would
put Women's Health at risk and undermine
fda's ability to keep safe and effective
medications available for people who
need them and it could open the
floodgates of attacks against any FDA
approved medication that Americans rely
on for care so today you'll hear from
the vice president vice president Harris
who will host a conversation in Reno
to talk about the administration's work
to protect Reproductive Rights including
new actions she announced last week to
safeguard patient privacy the stakes of
this could not be higher it could not be
higher and we're going to remain focused
on prevailing in the court so that women
can access the care they need without
without government interference
all right next up as you know it's tax
day happy tax day and we have some good
news for taxpayers I know people are
always excited about this day
yesterday we learned that thanks to new
funding from president's inflation
reduction act the IRS has significantly
improved customer service you see this
to my left here this tax season the IRS
answered 2.4 million more calls than
last year cut phone weights time from 27
minutes to four minutes that's what you
see here in this graphic behind me
served 87 percent of customers who
called up from just just 15 percent
called up from 17 15 last year pardon me
and helps a hundred thousand more
taxpayers in person so now Mega
Congressional Republicans want to repeal
this progress making customer services
worse for hard-working taxpayers and
making it easier for wealthy tax cheats
and big corporations to get away with
cheating on their taxes so it's
literally the first bill that the House
Republicans have passed that's how they
want to move forward here President
Biden Congressional Democrats have a
different agenda more help for taxpayers
while ensuring the super rich pay what
they owe that's what we're seeing today
finally and finally
award on the discussion today of the
debt limit and the budget
so you've heard the president share his
father saying don't tell me what you
value show me your budget and I will uh
and and I will that will show us you the
American people what you value and you
hear the president say that over and
over again you've heard me say that uh
repeating the president from time to
time here at the podium and here's the
thing we still haven't seen a budget
from House Republicans
what we have seen from them are
trickle-down proposals that would sell
out hard-working Americans speaker
McCarthy McCarthy doubled down on many
of these proposals yesterday and the
Republican conference has advanced
others that would
kill jobs by sending manufacturing
plants were delivering overseas and
medicare's new power we gave it to
negotiate lower drug costs increase
energy costs while increasing the
deficit take food assistance and Health
Care away from millions make devastating
cuts to Veterans benefit and education
to fund law enforcement and border
security
they're even talking about adding three
trillion dollars to our debt in wasteful
tax giveaways to the richest Americans
and big corporations compare that to
what we're trying to do compare that to
what this President is fighting for
today he's taking unprecedented actions
on behalf of hard-working families to
make child care more affordable improve
home care for veterans and improve care
for older Americans he's laid out how to
shrink the deficit by three trillion
dollars by ending wasteful subsidies for
rich rich special interests and having
them pay their fair share that's all
we're asking for them to pay their fair
share also by expanding the power
he gave Medicare to reduce lower drug
costs he's fighting to pick up the pace
of the reshoring trend he's leading
right now he wants to support law
enforcement with funding for community
policing and to ban assault weapons so
that we can reduce gun crime and save
lives and he wants to preserve our most
basic rights like the right of women to
make their own health care decisions
so again we'd like to see a republican
budget we have not seen one yet so that
the American people can see for
themselves in a transparent way what is
it that House Republicans want to do but
one thing that we know that is clear is
that this president President Biden's
budget shows his priority is delivering
for hard-working Americans and one last
thing before I go I promise I will be
taking questions momentarily
um
it's been a while since I've been in
here so
um so I want to make sure that I
introduce you to a a fresh face in our
briefing room today Kelly Scully has
joined our team as assistant press
secretary from her former role as
communications director at ondcp she's a
veteran of the Biden campaign and and
the Senate and we're excited to have her
on our team and and she'll be covering
health care and adjacent issues to
health care so uh you know please come
back and say hello to Kelly we're really
excited to have her but I wanted to make
sure that I introduced her while I have
that while I had the second with our
very long topper for all of you and with
that song maybe you want to kick off the
first question two topics on your last
one
um on the debt limit package I know the
president did a pretty thorough rebuttal
in the Rose Garden of the various
proposals that I've been brought out
there but there's an emerging thought
today Among Us Republicans that
repealing the inflation reduction act
has to be part of this debt limit
package so I wanted to get the White
House's impression of that offer so
let's be clear what uh Mega attacks on
the inflation reduction act would mean
for American families I'm going to lay
this out for you and I kind of talked
about it a little bit but this has a
little bit of Fuller uh a fuller layout
so offshore tens of thousands of
manufacturing jobs including in
districts many of these members actually
represent
so they're doing their job there I see
send investments in Supply chains back
to China raise costs for prescription
drugs insulin and home utility bills
remember that's kind of the core of what
the inflation reduction act and what
you've heard us say over and over it
will hurt American Energy Independence
protect wealthy tax cheats and make it
harder to get refunds from the IRS
increase the deficit in the name of
special interest like big farmer and
billionaires because as we know the
inflation reduction act actually helps
in reducing the deficit and so this is
what they would be doing if Mega
Republicans get their way this is what
the attacks lay out and what they would
be repealing as well these really quick
key critical important issues that
matter to the American people and guess
what this is an un unpopular agenda that
the Americans do not support they don't
support this so why would they go
against what majority of the Americans
want to do and this is going to hurt
their own District in that hurt them and
the Americans and their constituents in
their own district
one on Sudan are there plans to evacuate
U.S embassy Personnel from there so just
a couple things uh at the
um
a couple things I want to say about that
and do you mean Americans more broadly
are you talking about well okay so look
the U.S embassy in cartoons uh security
alert on April 16th uh stated that due
to uncertainty secure uncertain security
situation and Khartoum enclosures of the
airport Americans should have no
expectations of a U.S government
coordinated evacuation at this time
we expect that will remain the case we
have been urging American citizens not
to travel to Sudan since at least back
in October of last year when the state
department travel advisory was set at a
level four which means do not travel
that's what a level four means it is
imperative that U.S citizen in Sudan
make their own arrangements to safe to
stay safe in these difficult
circumstances we advise U.S citizens to
remain sheltered in place and to contact
the U.S embassy if they need assistance
and that is currently where we are at
this time what about the embassy
so look we have no higher priority to
make sure that uh our government to keep
make sure that the safety of our U.S
government personnel and their families
overseas that is clearly a priority for
this Administration the state department
plans for all contingencies to ensure
their safety uh depending on local
conditions but we have nothing imminent
at this time to announce we have made
clear to both sides that any attacks
threats or dangers are dangers opposed
to our diplomats are totally
unacceptable and you've heard from
secretary blinken directly uh yesterday
on this particular issue
uh we saw Evan gerskovich today for the
first time since he was detained
obviously Russia's denying his appeal I
wanted to get your reaction to that um
but also ask you about well actually we
can get International okay yeah we do we
do have something at the top uh look
we're we're deeply concerned by the news
that Russia will continue to wrongfully
detain Evan following a sham judicial uh
proceeding today and that's what we saw
earlier today the Biden Harris
Administration is engaging with Russia
through every available channel to bring
Evan and fellow American Paul Wayland
home who is also a priority for us and
you have you have heard us talk uh speak
to that for the past several months and
as we have said before the charges
against Evan are baseless and we call on
Russia for Russian Federation to
immediately release him we also call for
the immediate release of Paul who has
been wrongfully detained on sham
Espionage charges for more than four
years
we remain in touch with their families
and admire their courage in the face of
these unimaginable circumstances I know
you had a follow-up to that Paul Whelan
um they're both he and Evan gershowitz
are being charged with Espionage you
just called them sham Espionage charges
does the U.S believe that that freeing
Evan is going to be just as difficult as
it has been to bring Paul Whelan home
given the similarity of charges so look
I'm not gonna look
these are always challenging
circumstances right as we have known and
uh we've seen this play out under this
Administration uh this past two years
not going to get into hypotheticals I'm
not going to get into negotiations in
public or from the podium as you can
understand these are sensitive
sensitive matters so I just want to be
incredibly careful from here but don't
want to get ahead of that just know that
we are committed to bringing them both
home Leland's family is concerned though
and has been vocal about their concerns
the administration might leave Paul
behind in fact his sister Elizabeth is
now pausing her interactions with the
administration because she says she
won't re-engage until you quote stop
wasting her time and come up with
something more than thoughts and prayers
I don't want to discuss
um private conversations or meetings or
interactions uh between the natural
National Security Council and families
who are wrongfully detained what I can
say is this is a president who's
committed to um to getting U.S citizens
who are wrongfully detained and being
held hostage home and so that is a
commitment that you have seen that
you've seen from this President the last
two years but definitely don't want to
go in a back and forth in public
we are we remain in touch with their
families and certainly admire their
courage and in the face in the in the
current challenges that we are where
they are currently facing and it's
certainly unimaginable and so but don't
want to get into private interactions or
go back and forth with the family
thank you Julie Sue's confirmation
hearing is set for this Thursday
um given how some Democrats have been
talking about their reservations when it
comes to her and her record
um is the White House confident that you
will have the votes needed so good uh
here's what we're confident and uh
because of her proven track record as
you have just laid out in your question
about talk speaking about her tracker
records and her track record you see it
across working across the aisle sitting
down with business Community as well as
organized labor and delivering strong
results for the American economy and
that's why Julie was unanimously con
confirmed as a deputy secretary of Labor
let's not forget she actually went
through this process before it was done
by all Senate Democrats at that time and
so that's why Julie's nomination has
been endorsed by a range of business
groups I'll list them out for you right
now from business from small business
majority majority of to labor to La
Chamber of Commerce and labor leaders
from United Mine Workers to nabtu and to
Luna to IBEW as you know she served
under Marty Walsh's or served as his
right hand Marty Walsh's right hand for
the last two years as they helped
produce historic job growth as we've
seen we've heard us talk about the 12.5
million jobs that has been created under
this Administration 800 000
manufacturing jobs this is something
that uh you know that certainly the
Department of Labor and as herself and
and Marty Walsh were very directly
involved in so we're looking forward to
the hearing coming up on Thursday and
feel confident uh to your question we do
feel confident about Julie's
confirmation process again she has a
proven track record that she can stand
on proudly and we are proud to have not
the president is proud to have nominated
her camera things for support I mean
have you heard from Senator Testo or of
course Center Mansion has privacy
Express reservations what's the what's
the you know the feedback that you're
getting so again I I'm not going to
speak for any Senators I will let the
Senators that you just named speak for
themselves but again she went through
this process as deputy and got all
Democrats
in the Senate and so she has been
through this process before and so again
we're confident uh to uh uh to her
getting through and we look forward to
the hearing that's coming on Thursday a
different topic um I have a question on
uh the secret police uh Station in New
York on behalf of the Chinese government
and two men were arrested yesterday on
charges that they helped establish this
on behalf of the Chinese government uh
heavy because the White House and the
administration spoken to China
can you give us an update on so a couple
things the U.S government has been clear
that we will use all available tools to
protect American citizens and other U.S
persons from trans National repression
and other forms of foreign malign
influence we will not tolerate the PRC
uh government or any foreign government
harassing or threatening U.S persons uh
any other specific questions on this
particular arrest I would refer you to
Department of Justice
family
practice Crews from a broader
perspective
the president's Viewpoint what does it
say about the country that a black
teenager could bring the doorbell at the
wrong house and get shot in the head
look it's devastating I think gun
violence epidemic more broadly is
devastating uh and
um as you know he's as you just
mentioned in your question uh he spoke
to uh he spoke to Ralph and and his mom
and look I don't want to get too far
into it as you know there is going to be
an investigation so I want to be very
careful from here and uh they spoke at
length as I mentioned they discussed his
success in classrooms
um but look this is an epidemic that we
need to deal with I am tired I'm sure
you all are tired having to report on
these types of shooting almost every
week
and we can fix this Congress can fix
this
they can take action today and deal with
some real uh issues that we're seeing to
make to really deal with gun reform and
we're not seeing that you know the
president we get asked often why is it
that the president keeps asking for
Congress to take action because he's
using the platform that he has to speak
directly to Congress and to make it
clear that we need to take action this
is unacceptable what we're seeing is
unacceptable you heard the president say
this it is outrageous and unacceptable
it is unacceptable that guns are leading
killer in our children
and those numbers are just Rising
they're not declining when you think
about
our children dying uh by guns
and so
look I'm not going to get again too far
into the Weeds on this case but what I
can say is that um
uh you know like the president said to
him we hope for his speedy recovery and
we're going to continue to do everything
that we can to really deal with this
epidemic this is a president that has
put forward
almost a dozen executive actions to deal
with this issue and he's going to
continue to use to use the bully pulpit
to call on Congress to act
before you go on the audio back here we
can't hear no one can hear back here is
that right folks I'm sorry maybe someone
maybe
you know somebody somebody on the team
get that fixed I apologize guys no no
it's good to know maybe maybe it'll get
to it sorry about that I'll try to speak
louder
ask the question from a broader language
because I'm not sure what in the
president's proposals related to gun
reform would have addressed
the weapon used in this case or specific
scenario here that's why I'm asking kind
of more broadly what does it say about
the country that this is
if this can happen well look there's an
investigation I think it just went up
yeah I just woke up a second for a
second there there's an investigation
going on and we'll learn more as the
investigation goes by what we can say is
continue
um to lay out what we're seeing
our children
our schools our churches our grocery
stores they've all become targets and
that is a devastating to hear when I
started out talking about the gun
violence that we have seen over the last
couple days I said I just said this to
you in answering this question
almost it feels like almost every week
at least once a week we are having
discussion there was one week where the
president talked about gun reform and
gun violence three times and that's when
we saw that horrific shooting in
Nashville where three nine-year-olds and
three administrators were murdered at
school
and so what I can speak to is that
there's clearly an epidemic there's
clearly actions that need to be taken
we are asking Congress to take actions
and uh and this is something that they
can do today
this is a president that's taking this
very very seriously not just as
president as vice president as Senator
his record shows that but now we need
legislation we need courage on the other
side of 60 on the other side of
Pennsylvania and we just haven't seen
that yet from Republicans Republicans
need to act here
uh what is the White House's reaction to
Mitch McConnell saying that Republicans
would block attempts by democrats to
temporarily temporarily replace Dianne
Feinstein on the Judiciary Committee
look I want to be very clear here let me
first say
um that in the president and the first
lady has offered up you know uh you know
a speedy recovery as you have heard me
say many times that Senator Feinstein is
not just a former colleague of the
president but a friend and so was her
late husband Richard and so certainly we
wish her a speedy recovery and look this
is a decision for her to make when it
comes to the Future her future that is
something that she gets to make and and
should be allowed to to do that and what
we know and what the president has said
is she's had a an a a impressive career
he's worked alongside her with dealing
with the assault band weapons that's
something that they worked on together
and and the work that she's done as a
senator has certainly lifted up this
country as it relates to I'm not going
to
um I'm not going to speak to every uh
Senator or every elected official that
makes a comment uh but look what we
believe when you think about what
Democrats are doing or or what their
request this is a request that that is
we think that is reasonable this is
something that Senator Feinstein asked
for this is her request and it is uh
flat wrong to ask partisan to take to
seek partisan Advantage from from health
issues of a colleague right the American
people reject that kind of scorch earth
type of behavior approach to governing
again this is uh this is something that
she put forward and this was her request
so I'll leave it there the first seat on
the committee is not filled while she's
away with her illness I mean is it going
to hurt the White House's ability to get
judges appointed in the Senate so look
what we appreciate the efforts that we
have seen in confirming judges and what
we believe look confirming those judges
will uphold the rule of law is a type
priority for the president Senators
should not needlessly deny Community
judges who can't ensure accountability
for criminal acts and so um that's what
we believe and I'll just leave it there
I'm back on Evan gershkovitz you
mentioned that the administration is
using every possible Avenue to try to
talk to the Russians
have there been any substantive
negotiations or even conversations about
Evan between U.S officials and Russian
officials yet so as you can imagine I
can't get into details from here these
are sensitive uh
conversations uh don't want to get into
negotiating in public or negotiating
from the podium what I can say is that
we are we are committed to getting Evan
home and we are committed to getting
Paul Whelan home and you know that is
what you heard from the secretary
yesterday and that was is what you're
going to continue to hear from this
President
um I know that the U.S ambassador was
able to meet with Evan for the first
time yesterday
has any message been delivered from
President Biden to Evan so don't have
any direct message to to report out they
they report that he was appreciative of
the support that he is receiving uh from
from people at home and that he feels
good and is holding strong and I think
that's important to get a uh you know a
state of how Evan is doing and so that's
what we heard from Embassy Moscow and so
again I think that's important but I
don't have any direct
communication that was provided to Evan
from this person sorry no how often is
Evan going to be able to meet with the
U.S ambassador going forward so look uh
I don't have any specific timelines on
how often that's going to occur uh
clearly uh Evan's uh
uh health is very important to us which
is why we wanted Embassy Moscow to see
him and to uh to get to see him for
their own with their own eyes just don't
have a regular Cadence of what that's
going to look like and so I will leave
that to the state department to speak to
directly
so much Kareem yesterday John Kirby said
that the Brazilian president was
repeating Russia and China's propaganda
when he says the United States is
somehow
responsible for the war in Ukraine and
some officials are saying behind the
scenes that Brazil was trying to help
Russia in this conflict so two questions
does the White House believe
Lula's comment undermines his effort to
meditate peace he was trying to create a
group of neutral countries and also
another question could there be any
diplomatic implications against Brazil
from the U.S
so I'll say there's a couple of things
that I do want to say about this is that
the U.S and you've heard us say this
many times has no objection to any
country that seeks to try to bring an
end to Russia's war against Ukraine
against against uh against Ukraine a war
that they've started a war of their
choice this is Russia that I'm speaking
about clearly but we are we were struck
by uh to your question about the
comments we were struck by those tone of
the press conference of the foreign
minister yesterday which was uh not a
tone of neutrality and suggesting that
the United States and Europe are not
interested in peace or that we share
responsibility for their for the war we
believe and it is true that it is
plainly wrong
of course we want this war to end of
course we do and we support president
zielinski's call for just end to
Russia's war of choice
in fact the United States and EU
actively engage Putin to prevent the war
dating back to at least mid mid 2021 and
efforts have continued since the start
of this war
unfortunately Russia has shown no
interest in ending its unprovoked
Invasion we will continue to work with
our allies as you've seen this President
do over and over again this past year
and our allies and our partners to help
Ukraine defend itself against Russia
Russian aggression while supporting
Ukraine's proposal for a just and
durable peace that respects the U.N
charged harder and the principles of
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
because remember this is Ukraine's uh
territorial sovereignty and territorial
Integrity that Russia invaded and to say
and and again what we heard the tone was
not neutral and it is not true and so
we'll you know we'll continue to speak
out against that just like you heard
from uh from Admiral Kirby yesterday
do you think is President Biden aware of
those comments and going back to the
implications do you see any implications
against Brazil or diplomatic so look I
um I have not spoken to the president
I'm assuming that he is aware of this uh
and uh look again the Brazil is a
sovereign country and they get to make
its own decision and so I will leave it
there and uh you know and again I'll
just say that you know we are I'll say
this we are confident uh in the strength
of the U.S Brazil relationship uh even
if we disagree with some of the things
that uh the president president Lula
said uh we are still confident in that
in that engagement in that relationship
just as a very quickly one about Mexico
because the president of Mexico just
accused the Pentagon of skionage against
his country do you have any reaction to
that I have not seen those uh those
comments that just happened just now I
haven't seen those comments so I can't
speak to this at this time
okay great I have a question about
Judiciary but first I wanted to follow
up on Ralph Lauren I wonder if you can
talk about how the president learned
about and ingested the news and a
presidential phone calls is significant
and rare thing you know why did he
decide to make this phone call and then
tell the nation that he did it
so I think also uh the president uh the
the parents spoke to the phone call as
well I think you guys heard directly
from the parents who spoke to the call
that the president had with Ralph uh and
I think he also heard from others who
are um who are supporting uh Ralph in
this moment look
you guys heard the news it was a
devastating a 16 year old
a sweet kid as he's being is being
reported
um
was shot in the head
twice
um this is a president
As We Know
understands loss
um
understands the importance of
of making sure that he's a president
that's there when a when a family is
suffering and dealing with a hard time
um and that's what you saw this is a
president having to deal with another
shooting talking to another family
about what they're going through with
their kid being shot
for ringing
the wrong doorbell again I want to be
very careful there's still investigation
going on so I don't want to get ahead of
it but
that's what we know thus far
and so the president wanted to reach out
to the family and to Ralph and to say
that you know we wish him a speedy
recovery have a conversation let them
know that he and the first lady are with
them and I don't think that's unusual or
non-common for this president to do
and Terry good Judiciary
um I wonder if the president of the
White House is concerned that uh
committee assignments which usually have
been performable for now are stalling of
judicial nominees is going to just
become par for the courts in the Senate
and kind of stall you guys's ability to
create judicial nominees through look I
mean I just spoke to this about how
important it is to confirm judges and
what it means for our rule of law
um and uh you know to ensure there's
accountability so we we believe that is
it is a top priority and will continue
to be a top priority for this President
I can't speak to what Congress is going
to do or not do what the Senate is going
to do or not do I can't speak to
hypotheticals from here what I can tell
you is what the president's priority are
and this is continues to be a priority
for this president
all right thanks Carrie
um is the president following the the
drip trip of of uh questionable
Financial stuff happening from Justice
Thomas's uh
private life I've not spoken to the
president about this so I can't speak to
that what I can say is we're going to be
very careful from here and not comment
on that
how about um can you give a little
preview of the bilap with the Colombian
the president uh yes
yes I can give you a little preview
President Joe Biden will host president
Gustavo Petro of Colombia for a
bilateral meeting at the White House
Columbia is a key partner of the United
States and during the meeting the two
leaders will discuss how the United
States and Colombia can continue to
deepen our strong bilateral relationship
by making progress on areas of mutual
National interest including promoting
further economic and security
cooperation the two leaders will also
discuss joint efforts to combat climate
change Counter Narcotics trafficking
address our regional migration Challenge
and promote democratic values in human
and labor rights in the region and
around the world and we certainly will
have more to share as you know we tend
to have these background calls these
preview calls we'll have one tomorrow
and certainly we'll have more to share
till for all of you I'm going to try and
take one in the back go ahead Courtney
thank you I wanted to ask about
immigration we're preparing for next
month for title 42 to lift and for more
people to be eligible to apply for
Asylum we saw that new border numbers
are out for March and there's been the
vast majority of Migrant encounters are
from Mexico and Central America I know
you've got a program separately for a
couple other nations where you saw a lot
of people coming from there but can you
talk about how you're preparing for next
month particularly with
people coming from these particular
nationalities
so tooth you kind of asked a couple of
things let me just touch on the March
numbers for a second as you just stated
Look
What We believe is our Board of
enforcement measures and what we have
seen continue to limit unlawful
immigration so that is important to note
we typically see an increase in Border
Encounters this time of the year as
whether as you I'm sure you've reported
as whether it gets warmer and we uh you
know but what we want to note and what's
notable is that the seasonal increase
this time around was the lowest in two
years and the number of people
attempting to cross unlawfully last
month was down about 23 percent from
this time last year and will continue to
do what we can to build a safe quarterly
and Humane immigration system but as
you've heard me say many times Congress
needs to act and to also show that they
truly show have real concern and not do
political stunts when it comes to the
Border as we as you've heard from the
Secretary of Homeland Security they put
out a plan back in January and what the
process would look like and and we're
continuing to implement that plan once
uh title 42 is lifted and as you know
and we've talked about this we're
expanding legal Pathways like parole
parolee parolee program for for migrants
from Venezuela Nicaragua Haiti and Cuba
and we have actually seen the numbers
come down by more than 90 percent uh
we're working with our partners Across
the Western Hemisphere to jointly manage
migration patterns we're surging
additional resources including personnel
and Technology to the border and we're
ramping up expedited removals under
title eight so again
we uh Department of Homeland Security uh
put out their their plan back in January
and they're going to be implementing
that plan and I just laid out some of
the things that they announced that
they're going to be doing and we're
going to be really focused on making
sure that we have a Humane orderly
process when it comes to the Border
question for you at the Supreme Court
Justice Alito put a hole or not a fold I
should say but we're expecting as soon
as tomorrow we could get a decision on
that the price down can you talk about
how you're preparing for that both from
a not necessarily a political
perspective but a practical one when so
many patients rely on this medication
yeah and so I spoke to about that a
little bit at the top as you know the
vice president is going to be in uh is
uh is currently traveling right now
Nevada and she's talking she's been
she's been leading on this for the past
week she's going to be talking at a
round table to talk about how we're
moving forward we we announced some
actions last week the privacy on HIPAA
what we're doing to strengthen that and
I think that of course very important
for now mifa Presto remains available
and approved for safe and effective use
I'm certainly not going to get ahead of
the courts but this is certainly an
Administration the president and the
vice president who have taken this very
seriously and will continue to fight for
fundamental freedoms we're talking about
fundamental freedoms for women and this
is something that the president or this
vice president is not going to back away
from and again I laid out some actions
that we've taken in the past week but
not going to get ahead of of the courts
as you just said they're going to be
deciding at some point tomorrow
um I have a question on migrant issues
and on Afghanistan starting with
Afghanistan the UN says they're prepared
to make the heartbreaking decision to
pull out un staff if the Taliban won't
allow women to work for them
um you know what what is the White
House's reaction to this possibility and
how could this affect assistance to
Afghanistan so look uh we've been very
I've talked about this many times about
um you know the Taliban and and if they
want to be taken seriously uh if they uh
want us to have a a real conversation
with with them they have to they have to
behave in a way for example where where
women are treated uh in a respectful way
I'm not going to I'm going to let the UN
speak to uh speak to their uh to their
decisions
um you know and uh you know again
um
look we're assessing the situation
closely uh and uh with the UN and our
other partners
um and uh look when it comes to uh you
know women not being able to work at the
UN that is something that we've talked
about and we've said that we were
extremely concerned uh with uh with yet
another horrific Taliban action uh you
know women are essential to humanitarian
and Civil Society operations around the
world in Afghanistan in particular only
women are able to reach some of the most
vulnerable in part because of many of
the most uh most vulnerable are
women-headed households that male Aid
workers cannot enter and so women must
be able to work for the UN as I've
talked about so that millions of Afghans
can receive Food medicine and other
basic needs for their survivals they are
essential to the delivery of of this
assistance and essential to ensuring
women children and other members of
vulnerable groups receive the necessary
types of assistance such as protection
and gender-based violence services with
out risk of exploitation
so again I'm going to let the U.N speak
to their decision on on how they're
going to move forward but we've been
very explicit about this we've been very
clear
about our concerns with uh you know with
the taliban's tragic decision and
horrific decision on how they treat
women in Afghanistan on migrant issues
these disturbing reports of Migrant
children being forced to work how does
the White House respond to reports that
the administration repeatedly ignored
warnings about this and what are you
going to do next and then if I can just
follow up on Sudan real quickly what's
the consequence if these two warring
parties don't reach any sort of peace
agreement what what's the stick so the
first part is look it's unacceptable
that these companies are using child
labor you've heard us say this
when the first when the New York Times
story first was reported earlier this
year and we'll continue to say that what
I can say a couple of things that I can
say since the New York Times shined uh
light on on these abuses in February
this Administration moves swiftly to
crack down on violators and are more
rigorously vet response now more
vigorously vet sponsors of unaccompanied
minors DOL and HHS launched a new task
force to heighten cooperation and better
share information we also called on
Congress to provide the resources this
Administration has long requested to
help us crack down on companies that
exploit children for labor the actions
we've taken since February make clear
that we will continue to investigate and
hold companies accountable but we also
need Congress to provide the resources
we need to enforce and we have been very
clear again DOL HHS has taken actions
but we need Congress to also to also
give the give d-o-l HSS sources that
they need to to broaden these actions
that they've put forward
it's for the warring parties in Sudan
um look you know we've been very clear
about the importance of de-escalating
and you've heard secretary Lincoln speak
to this you heard my colleague from NSC
speak to this as well
and so I'm just not going to go beyond
to what they have said I'm going to take
a couple more questions
the president when he was traveling
abroad last week said he wasn't that
worried because they weren't
contemporaneous but in the days since
we've learned that several close allies
are Furious and there have been some
difficult conversations with high-level
U.S officials about how to prevent this
from happening again so can you just
speak to what role the president is
playing in managing the Fallout so yeah
look the president has taken this this
matter very seriously to the point where
he asked the military to do a couple of
things the military and the intelligence
Community to do a couple of things to
run a high priority senior level
interagency process focused on
understanding what happened take steps
to further secure and limit distribution
of sensitive information nation and
reach out directly to allies and
partners to reassure to assure them
about our commitment to safeguarding
intelligence and so those are the things
that the president has asked again his
the military and also the intelligence
Community to do he expressed his concern
that the leak happened and uh and we are
and he is taking this incredibly
seriously I have to move around because
I'm just going to move around make sure
I take one or two I have to take one or
two questions before we go Ben
yesterday the Japanese prime minister
kishida's wife was here uh could you let
us know a little bit how that went and
then the upcoming G7 next month is going
to be in Japan what are some
expectations from the upcoming Summit so
look on the second question we'll have
more to share don't have anything to
share or confirm at this time or what
the expectations would be or what the
goals are from here so certainly will as
we normally do as we get closer to the
date we'll have more to share I believe
we have a we have a readout of
the meeting that the first lady had and
we'll I'm happy to share that but I'm
going to continue to move around go
ahead Steve thanks two questions if I
could related to electric vehicles the
first Senator management is a statement
today in which he indicates he would
support a resolution disapproval of the
epa's emission standards that were
announced last week while we were in
Ireland he says that they would increase
Reliance on chinese-made batteries and
make a more energy secure and Powerful
China and responsive so look the
measures the EPA propose will if
implemented do the following save
American drivers and truck companies an
average of twelve thousand dollars over
the lifetime of their vehicle which is
incredibly important they they'll cut
nearly 10 billion 10 billion tons of CO2
emissions that's nearly twice annual U.S
emissions they'll strengthen American
Energy security by reducing Reliance on
20 million barrels of oil and together
with the historic investment that the
president has already made has secured
to build more electric cars here in
America and they'll put United States on
a path to out-compete China you hear us
talk about that often for jobs and
Investments building the future of
transportation and so that's how we see
the president's electric vehicle program
being his focus on that and this is what
we think it's going to deliver for the
American people as well as really
fighting climate change the second
question related to electric vehicles
this has been a controversy it's been
bubbling up for months now but I wanted
to raise it to you the seven last FEMA
administrators have objected to and they
won't raise serious safety concern about
the idea that electric vehicles are not
able to receive the stations that have
been licensed by the federal government
to operate on the impact on the am band
in addition to news and information this
involves stations that uniquely serve
black communities Hispanic communities
Asian communities and other underserved
communities last week Sean Hannity
suggested that this had something to do
with trying to snuck out conservative
voices and Democrats Ed Markey and Josh
gottheimer have suggested that the
administration ought to do more to
encourage automakers to have some sort
of engineering fix to see two of the EVS
can receive these stations licensed by
the government to operate on the am band
what's your response so Julia here the
questions look while AM stations have uh
is a critical tool to get information to
the American people there it's not the
only tool in their other there are other
ways of doing that FEMA works with
dozens of wireless service providers and
Commercial and public radio and TV
stations to get key alerts out that is
something that they have been working on
and again with dozens of wireless
service provide writers what's important
is that any car manufacturer planning to
remove AM radio should make sure it is
paired with a a suitable proven and free
alternative to receive critical
information again this is something that
FEMA takes very seriously working with
providers but it's not again it's not
the only tool to providing critical
information to the American people
because there are parts of this country
where there's still no cell service
so how does that work if you don't try
to use an app no I totally understand
this is why FEMA is taking this very
seriously having those conversations
with uh providers making sure that that
critical information that is needed to
be provided to the American people
occurs and happens but again it is not
the only way AM stations is not the only
way to provide that for information
we've proven that by working with other
providers and so we're going to continue
to address this issue we understand it
is important for communities that you
just listed to get that information and
this is something that FEMA certainly is
taking very seriously I'm going to take
one more question before I I gotta go
um
listen just to close the book in Ireland
since we just got back it was a highly
personal trip there were a lot of
cousins there you did Valerie
and Hunter Biden the Sloan Air Force One
did they contribute did they pay for
airfare accommodations ground
transportation what I think we took we
this is not the first time let's be very
very clear it is consistent with other
presidents when they've had family
travel with them abroad this is nothing
new so just want to make sure that we
make that very clear to the American
people and of course we followed every
protocol that any other president or
every other president has taken when
they when their family has traveled and
so yes all right
so we we took every protocol that is
necessary and needed when a family
travel we did nothing different than
past presidents and so yes they paid
they paid for their way
to share yeah like every other this is
this is not unusual this is not the
first time that families have traveled
uh with presidents so there's there's
nothing there's no there there as they
were saying all right thank you